ضمن سياسه الاحتلال المتواصله لاقتحام مدن
الضفه بدا الاقتحام الجديد لمخيم الفارعه
هنا في هذه اللحظات حيث تصل تجهيزات
عسكريه اسرائيليه جديده الى مخيم الفارعه
قبل لحظات وصلت القوات الخاصه وحاصرت محيط
المخيم ايه وحيث وصلت الى ساحه المخيم بعد
ذلك بدا الاحتلال بالدفع بالتعزيز
العسكريه الاسرائيليه نحو المخيم في عمليه
عسكريه اسرائيليه بالفعل جديده واشتباكات
مسلحه تدور في هذه اللحظات والانفجارات
التي لا تكد تهدا هنا الاليات العسكريه
عشرات الاليات العسكريه برفقه الجرافه
التي وصلت بالفعل الى محيط المخيم بدا
بالدخول تباعا نحو ساحه المخيم وسط
الاشتباكات والانفجارات المتتاليه قبل اقل
من اسبوعين كان هناك اقتحام اخر لمخيم
الفارعه نفذ خلالها الاحتلال عمليه عسكريه
اعتقل اربعه مقاومين من داخل هذا المخيم
وفي هذه اللحظات عمليه جديده حتى هذه
اللحظه اصابه واشتباكات لا تزال متواصله
من محيط مخيم الفارعه في مدينه طوباس ليث
جعار
الجزيره